pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un ministre des finances quitte l'elysée
un autre y entrent monsieur antoine
pinay a laissé la place de grand
argentier de la vème république à
monsieur wilfried beau gartner qui est
depuis 11 ans gouverneur de la banque de
france
rien de changé dans la politique
financière de la france
à l'hôtel matignon le premier ministre
monsieur michel debré a tourné une page
de l'histoire africaine
en ouvrant les négociations avec les
délégués de la fédération du mali qui
regroupe le sénégal et le soudan
ces négociations doivent en effet
aboutir à l'indépendance du mali
mais cette indépendance prendra une
forme unique au monde le mali tient à
rester dans la communauté
on s'en doutait mais on ne le savait pas
officiellement aujourd'hui c'est fait la
france compte 45 millions d'habitants
l'institut national de la statistique
à qui la question était posée a mises en
oeuvre ces machines électroniques pour
découvrir ce quarante cinq millionième
français l'afficheur forêt qu'ils
désignaient tomber on s'est reportée aux
dossiers correspondants et voilà le
quarante cinq millionième français est
un enfant du sexe masculin du nom de
claude maigrot né le 2 mai 1959 à
hérimoncourt dans le tout c'est là que
nous sommes allé l'interviewer le
village était en pleines fêtes à la
mairie toute la commune se trouvaient
réunis fanfare comprise pour le voir
recevoir offerte par l'institut de la
statistique
sa première médaille déjà le français a
du goût pour les décorations salue donc
à claude les gros quarante cinq
millionième citoyens et premier médaillé
france 1 à 1 110 d'une rare violence a
détruit le plus important le plus
moderne des ateliers de la lainière de
roubaix où travaillent et 800 ouvriers
ceux ci ont pu être évacués sans dommage
et le feu n'a causé que des dégâts
matériels
ces dégâts sont considérables l'atelier
qui vient de brûler quatorze mille
mètres carrés équipée des machines les
plus nouvelles faisait de cette filature
la plus importante de l'europe
occidentale
il ne reste rien de cet appareillage que
des ferrailles tordues un stock de 300
mille kilos de file est également
détruit en chiffres les dégâts à
quelques 15 millions de nouveaux freins
un milliard et demi d'hyères
[Musique]
une brèche de 75 mètres dans la digue du
canal de la mer du nord et ce fut la
catastrophe pour info bourgneuf
d'amsterdam green door au stade dont les
groupes d'habitations se sont
transformées en autant d'îlots pas
d'affolement pourtant la population a
été la familiarité avec les a sous les
flots
c'est dans le calme que s'est effectué
l'évaluation des 10000 habitants du
faubourg inondées chacun s'efforçant de
ne rien oublier de trop périssables
le lendemain le colmatage de la digue
était en voie d'achèvement
lorsque la reine juliana arrivait sur
les i ainsi une fois de plus la hollande
a dû reprendre sa lutte contre la mer
cette lutte qui dure depuis des siècles
[Musique]
ces images publiées aujourd'hui
seulement auront bientôt un an
filmée du côté des troupes chinoises
elle retrace le dernier épisode de la
révolte tibétaine
la prise de la sarre la capitale par les
soldats de maastricht
après des combats acharnés les lamas
révolté c'est détonant la garde
personnelle du dalaï lama
fini s'est elle aussi pas rendre les
armes livrant le palais sacré le potala
dix jours plus tôt le dieu roi avait fui
ce palais à marche forcée à travers les
plus hautes montagnes du monde ils
avaient cherché refuge dans l'inde du
président en héros
le panchen lama deuxième autorité
traditionnelle du tibet devenait le
premier personnage du pays sous l'égide
de l'autorité chinoise
ainsi ce tibet jusqu alors relativement
indépendant n'était plus qu'une province
de chine l'onu a été saisie de ce
problème
[Musique]
capitale de la république du liberia à
monrovia célébrer l'anniversaire de son
indépendance selon des rites où l'on
reconnaîtra facilement la trace des
traditions locales et l'influencé
américaine c'est ainsi qu'à la mode de
la maison blanche le président tout de
man
élu pour la quatrième fois a prêté
serment sur la bible
[Musique]
baisse est ainsi également le cortège
présidentiel où l'on retrouve le
souvenir de west paint a pris un rythme
très local pour gagner les salons
officiels
je
[Applaudissements]
là la haute société de monrovia fêtait
le nouvel événement de monsieur
tout-le-monde
[Musique]
et cette double appartenance n'est pas
le moindre charme ou compte retrouver au
liberia la première en date des
républiques africaines puisque sa
constitution date de 1847
l'air de paris n'est pas exactement ce
qu en disent les chances et les
pancartes les plus optimistes ne peuvent
rien contre les fumées de la capitale
sur laquelle chaque année nous disent
les experts retombe 13000 tonnes de
poussière rançon du progrès l'atmosphère
des grandes villes est chaque année un
peu plus pollués
[Musique]
il a bien fallu se pencher sur le
problème c'est ainsi que chaque jour des
équipes vont prélever des échantillons
d'air dans les différents quartiers
c'est ainsi que les laboratoires
spécialisés analyse en l'air que nous
respirons ont pu jeter la larme
paris est en train de s'intoxiquer paris
c'est à dire la foule parisienne et les
cheminées des usines ne sont pas seuls
en cause
il ya aussi les voitures dont les pots
d'échappement éjecte en particulier avec
l'oxydé de carbone se base aux 3/4
pyrène au nom barbare et qui est très
cancérogènes paris c'est à dire aussi
les arbres qui dépérissent sur les
avenues et qu'il faut remplacer
grâce aux prises d'air permanente c'est
petit entonnoir insolite apparu sur les
toits de paris
on a établi les diagrammes d'une journée
de respiration parisienne le
noircissement du filtre par les déchets
qui est intensif en soirée serait nulle
la nuit sans leur de cuisson du
boulanger jusqu'au matin où il reprend
devient donc urgent de limiter les
causes de pollution de l'air qui
menacent nos poumons d'antras cause et
autres facteurs pathogènes
sinon il faudra un jour nous résoudre à
d'ennuyeuse extrémité il faudra
peut-être changer le style de notre
oeuvre
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
même les présentations de mode ne
gagneront pas
[Musique]
kitzbühel où se déroule la nonne gamme
c'est un peu la mecque du ski autrichien
les français ont choisi justement cet
endroit pour prouver aux skieurs
autrichiens qui ne sont pas invincibles
même chez eux ici au salon spécial nous
assistons à la course du grand favori
l'autrichien style très à droite très
décontracté stiegler effectué un
parcours impeccable
ce qui n'empêche pas de renverser
quelques forces au passage avant de
franchir la ligne d'arrivée
mothern enfant chéri de kitzbuehl le roi
de la piste des mares moins bien que son
compatriote avec lui c'est une véritable
hécatombe
aucun obstacle ne lui résiste il est
même au bord de la chute qui marque la
fin de ses illusions et désillusions
français rien du billard on avait
beaucoup et il avait raison il pensait
qu'il était meilleur que les autrichiens
il le prouve en ce moment stiegler avait
étonné tout le monde du bia pluie
enthousiasme par la pureté de son style
par sa puissance par son audace son
exhibition trouve sa récompense avec une
excellente première place devant sigle
[Musique]
dubillard avait déjà gagné la veille la
descente à laquelle on assiste ici là
encore les autrichiens étaient mortifiés
ils ont été battus sur les pentes même
où ils ont fait leurs premiers pas voyez
ses concurrents il donne tout ce qu'il
peut
[Musique]
et voici adrien du bia à mi course sauf
accident tout le monde le considérait
déjà comme le vainqueur probable de la
descente il n'a pas eu d'accident il a
gagné facilement avec plus d'une seconde
et demie d'avancé
ainsi il a fallu attendre 25 ans pour
qu'un français battent les autrichiens
chez eux
c'est chose faite avec adrien duvillard
et ce n'est peut-être pas fini
maintenant attendons les prochains jeux
olympiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]